he lives in a castle in Scotland his
qlae track record has produced over
fifty billion dollars in equity for
entrepreneurs since 1993 he's the
founder of an investment consortium
specializing in facilitating
transactions he's Dan Pena and here's my
take on his top ten rules a success
volume six enjoy alright let's kick it
off with rule number one man up all UK
guys probably had bicycles with trainer
wheels right on the little wheels on the
side of the bicycle and when you ride it
and you didn't fall off and then when
the your parents took the trainer wheels
off what happened you fell over on your
head and what if your mother probably
maybe your father oh poor baby poor baby
and rub your head when I fell off my
bike my dad hit me if little weenies get
up stand up stop crying oh yeah
yeah I mean man up and now look at me I
mean I wish love got the job done I
swear to God I do but it doesn't
and God doesn't get the job done either
god helps those who help them himself
rule number two love what you do that's
the fun part in your life I'm having fun
right now I love what I do most of you
in this audience don't like what you do
that's what the greatest respect that's
what Michael can help you most of the
people on the 87th Gallup poll did a
survey in 2016 87% of the people on the
planet not counting all the by Afra you
know Ghana Kenya Cana countries 87
percent of the planet hate what they do
they've checked out they're just taking
up time waiting for retirement I'm sure
some of you in this room getting you
know relate to that 87 percent I've
checked out now to me if you've checked
out I mean what the hell Jesus and
you're all going to live older the 70 is
the new 50 they tell me I don't I don't
even feel 50 I feel 30 I act 30 I got
more energy than part of the whole room
yeah well because I loved dragging you
sorry guys and gals across the goal line
my wife beloved wife Sally says the
reason I have arthritis in my back is
because you're getting heavy now that
I'm getting older dragging across the
goal line but I will kick spit slap I
will do whatever it takes and when I say
I'll do whatever it takes I mean it I
will insult you your mother your
religion I know how to get you to the
top of the podium at the Olympics not
for a bronze medal not for silver before
gold if we're not going for gold don't
waste my time rule of a3 be courageous
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls what
it you could accomplish in the world
today if you weren't afraid if you
weren't afraid of what people thought of
you said about you whispered about you
what could you accomplish a lot more
than you've accomplished today
a lot more
why do we care what people think why do
we care what people say and more
importantly why do we care what people
whisper because we have no self-worth we
have a little next a little self-esteem
and we have no self-confidence and how
do we get that way yes mommy and daddy
life expands and contracts with courage
when was the last courage courage type
thing that you did in your lifetime walk
against the red light whisper that your
spouse or significant other is a bastard
when was the last time you exhibited
some courage some of you have to go back
a long long way
some of you never I said yesterday I
cannot believe that there are people in
this audience that have never been
spanked never had a harsh word said to
them by their parents never got in a
fight on the school grounds I can't
believe that and you wonder why you are
the way you are now I'm not saying that
being a high-performance person is
beaten not everybody but it doesn't hurt
rule number four push the envelope when
I was growing up
contrary to what you were growing up I'm
13 years old and I'm wrestling with
lions that's me and Jackie the lion
Jackie the line from the MGM lecture
Golda Meir that's the first line Jackie
so I'm not afraid to animals to this day
I'm wrassling my mother's over here out
of camera screaming and yelling afraid
that the lion is going to eat me and
then fast forward forty fifty years
there were Tigers you can see Sally in
the background there yes people get hurt
on these things yes people get killed on
these things that's why there's only
three people in that picture
and Sally and I went trekking with the
Lions a few years ago because I'm
continuing to push the envelope I never
want to be comfortable doing anything
also if you want to learn to have more
confidence check out my 254 series it's
free the link is in the description
below but no and I know initially
upfront you have to try if the swing at
the plate a kid like you you had to keep
track of seven days a week 24 hours a
day what you do rule number five master
selling if you're in sales make 300 cold
calls a day 300 cold calls a day 300
cold calls a day correct
will it still work yeah we got kids
doing it was a question we even got some
lazy Dutch kids doing it right now just
pick up the phone yeah yeah I mean for
us for a Dutch kid 24 years old to make
twenty cold calls a day you think it's a
big deal there's nobody's teaching sales
in this country that I'm aware of that
tells you that makes 300 cold calls a
day
in fact there's nobody on the planet
that I'm aware of that tells you to make
300 phone calls a day I had a guy just
do a 50 million dollar deal he said Dan
if you just told me I was 2,000 cold
calls away from my first deal I would
have sent you a check for 20 grand and
said thank you and I want to come to the
castle rule number six model success and
life is not a journey it's only if
you're a meathead clubfoot [ __ ] and if
those of you I'm not trying to if some
of you or issues retardation I'm not
trying to that's not what I'm talking
about that's how I'm talking about it's
a model you find someone as I said
yesterday after where he or she is where
you want to be and then you model them
you mimic them you copy them same way
you would if you want to be a footballer
saying what you want to be if you want
to be a golfer you don't copy some
monkey that can't break 100 do you
Socrates Plato Aristotle had this
figured out two or three thousand years
ago
what happen why'd we stop these are
arguably the first mentor-mentee
relationships that were existed on the
planet I'm not teaching anything new
guys gals I give credit to the man that
I copied Andrew Carnegie came up with a
cure lame island didn't call qlae
because he was a he could have been
Dutch really he was a meat mean cheap
person that didn't want to spend money
so he didn't allow equity in his
transactions he only used death as you
would say death so he would still own it
all and that's all I did he was doing it
140 years ago what I do rule number
seven have a dream but if you believe if
you believe in yourself I had to go up
Obama again Obama I had a dream I'm
running down Torrance Boulevard in 1983
and I had just looked at a magazine
called the rob report which I recommend
that you all subscribe to and it had
castles on islands in the and I said I'm
gonna buy a castle on an island that was
March 83 I moved into the Guthrie castle
September 1 84 had no way to pay for it
didn't have a more I had a pot to piss
in
but 15 months later was that 15 or 17
months anyway from March to September 1
the next year so I had an Obama moment
and I wasn't even cracked up I had a
dream so even though I make fun of these
guys that have a dream but I've had it
myself but if you don't have a dream
guess what it can't come true and you're
never going to exceed your highest
expectation you will never for those of
you that want to make a million dollars
you're never going to make a million in
one through liber8 surround yourself
with greatness
what can you do to build self-confidence
and self-esteem you are who you hang
around with show me your friends and
I'll show you your future show me your
friends and I'll show you your future
the first self-esteem is built the first
seven or eight years of life who are you
around for seven or eight years of life
mom maybe dad
older brother uncle a grandmother right
what the hell do they know about
building self-esteem they don't know
anything and now show me your friends
I'll show your future who do you go hang
with pretty chill with and I anti and he
he and I we disagree about a few things
but Bill Gates doesn't hang Steve Jobs
who I knew didn't chill Warren Buffett
doesn't hang a Elon Musk doesn't hang
and I go down the list of people that
don't hang very few people are happy
with what they're doing and if you want
to build self-esteem deal with people
that have high self esteem rule over
nine impact lots of people for those of
you that want to save the world go make
a bunch of money and then go save the
world
or more recently the last four or five
six years I've said figure out a system
a process a procedure an invention that
changes a billion lives and you'll
become you know multi billionaire ie
Facebook Zuckerberg unruly pretend the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is hold yourself accountable this
young kid he came to me a year and a
half ago his goal is dreaming his life
was finished number one University
champion Archer in Britain what's the
best you've ever done
xx in a regional meeting he said to me
so we set up a program and I beat him
like a rented mule that's him receiving
the first place a couple months ago and
Britain the little skinny he looks like
a little Nimrod snowflake who's he is
but he was firing six seven hundred
arrows a day most of you couldn't fire
fifty most of you in this room have
never been held accountable about
anything in your life and look at the
result I've got a special bonus clip
from then on how to want it bad enough
that I think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
where do you need to be more
rageous number two which three people
can you model success from a number
three what is your big dream you've
already read some of you that I am the
creator of teenage multimillionaires
from scratch and the met the meant eat
is the CEO of the largest deal in
recorded history the 500 billion dollar
deal neon the city of the future I
created them both just like God with
clay with these two hands I made them
just like God and everybody in between
which covers everybody in this room
teenage multimillionaire no school no
high school no junior high school no
college 17 years old why not you the
answer is it could be you but he's a
hard-working a hundred and forty hour
week worker not a eighty a good straight
a good drinker too stiff kill everybody
in this room and you're not in your head
yeah but some of you will just settle
for the good most guys come to me
because I'm the alpha male father that I
never had
most young guys come to me because they
can't get their willy wet now what the
world come to you got to come to our
raging crazy old man 72 years old to get
your willy wet what happened
almost everything bad that's what's
happened
if you want more dan Payne yeah check
out his top 50 rules video the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there this is what I'm training
you to be like the Four Horsemen of the
[ __ ] Apocalypse Adolf Hitler
might be the highest performance guy
that ever was born on the planet